oh hello hello everybody
welcome to ask doc live and
those of you who are on with us live
welcome to friday so excited um this is
one of my favorite days of the week
because i get to spend two hours
with all of you and my favorite doctor
in the world
so my name is rebecca kozak and i will
be your host for the next two hours here
on the askdoc live show
we are so excited to have you here with
us and i just want to remind you that if
somebody invited you to this program
whether it's live or to watch this video
replay we want to make sure that you get
back with the person that shared this
program with you
if you have any questions or would like
especially if you would like to get any
of the products that are going to be
mentioned on this program today
so this program is being brought to you
as a resource to help build a community
that is inspiring people to be empowered
and take more control over their own
health
the program
that you see today the replay is
available at askdoclive.com
including all of our replays that have
taken place
since we started this program july of
2020 so i'm so excited that we do have
this available for you
and that so many of you are jumping on
live with us and asking your questions
because questions that you have are
questions that others have as well and
we want to make sure that we're
answering
the
questions and the desires of real people
and that means you
so without further ado i just want to
thank my wonderful co-host jonty
mccollier who is our webmaster he has
taken care of all of the technical stuff
so i don't have to worry about it is
absolutely fabulous
and
this program
is is for you
but the content of this program is to
provide educational information only on
the importance of nutrition and
supplementation in a world where the
food supply is empty and void of what
the body
needs not just to survive but to thrive
in this program we will be sharing
nutritional options that are available
through supplementation in a form that
the body can readily absorb and utilize
because of its synergistic formulations
if you are on live with us today we do
have a chat function turned on
where
you can ask your questions but when you
ask your questions make sure you include
your age weight
gender
height
and your main health concern and any
concerns that you have
or any conditions that you have been
diagnosed with but we don't want you to
become that diagnosis we're all about
removing labels and addressing the body
as a whole
not just symptoms
the fda requires us to let you know that
our products are not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure any diseases
and this program again is not meant to
take the place of your primary care
physician
but we bring good news
the genetic theory has been proven
incorrect through the science of
epigenetics which is the study of how
your behaviors and environment can cause
changes that affect the way your genes
work
with epigenetics you are an empowered
individual and have more control than
you think of your health journey we
invite you to feel the difference with
the options shared in this program and
to guide us we are so honored to have
the man who has decades of research
under his belt
not just looking at somebody else's work
but doing the work himself also
we have the amazing dr joel wallach dr
wallach
welcome to askdoc live
thank you so much for joining us today
and every friday taking this two hours
out of your time because i know you have
a busy schedule but we so so so
appreciate you
well thank you so much rebecca for the
kind introduction and thank you dot t
for making things happen today
and um i cannot tell you how much i
appreciate these weekly
events we have to share information
my ultimate goal is to
add 25 to 50 healthful years every human
being's life on earth
to add 25 to 50 healthy years why would
you not want to spend another 25 to 50
years with the people you love why would
you not want to spend 25 to 50 extra
years doing the things you love to do
but you're going to have to kind of be a
little proactive here you're not going
to just be able to sit there watch tv
and do nothing and expect all this to
happen you got to be proactive but i'm
going to go back
um because we've got a big news release
coming out in the next week to 10 days
you've heard me say this i think last
week well
um
we were like 95 done with writing this
news release we've got just a little bit
more to put in it
and
it's going to be earth shaking literally
earth shaking this is
a
when it comes to earthquakes you know
three is bad seven is catastrophic 10 is
multi-catastrophic well this is going to
be information that is a 25 earthquake
okay
um i want to go back literally billions
of years ago when the earth was first
forming and it doesn't go against
biblical stuff in the old testament the
first sentence in genesis is in the
beginning god created the heavens and
the earth and but he didn't say
how long
the creation took place was it five
minutes five hours five days five years
fifty years five thousand years uh 500
000 years we don't know
but we'll give the lord all the credit
and then
we're talking
literally
billions of years ago when the earth was
forming
this is pretty well done with
publications
by people who
study these things and they have the
amounts of oxygen and carbon and sulfur
and stuff like that in the air from
fossilized
amber which is fossilized
sap from
trees and for the first
couple of billion years uh there was no
nothing living on land except maybe some
anaerobic bacteria you know bacteria
that didn't require oxygen
all the things that required oxygen were
in the ocean okay there was nothing on
earth other than these anaerobic
bacteria
and so that was quite a step and
all of these great
mass extinctions
of thousands of species of animals i
think there was 12
mass extinctions but there were five big
ones
and in these five big ones there were
thousands of species of animals
disappeared and
you know you used to say almost
overnight well i went back and looked
and sure enough that that was an
exaggeration almost overnight because
these mass extinctions took place each
time over a period of sixty thousand to
a hundred thousand years it didn't just
happen in five minutes or five days or a
month it was sixty thousand to a hundred
thousand years
and then we have these mass extinctions
again thousands of species and then we
have the dinosaurs
went extinct now they were the most
successful even yet today the most
successful vertebrates uh they're around
depending on whose work you look at
were around for
165 million to 235 million years before
they went extinct but they went extinct
for the same reason that the previous
bunch did
and
they were always associated with glacial
events
now today we have the dead zones we'll
come back and talk about that a minute i
think i've talked about it before but
it's worth repeating
and when there's over 401 dead zones
there used to be 400 now there's 400
there's a new one farming off the west
coast of oregon
near haystack rock and cannon beach
where i lived for 12 years had a little
clinic there on right where i saw people
on the weekends i had a clinic
in portland where i saw people during
the week
so i know that area very well
and so uh that that's the newest dead
zone
the
um
dead zone
that's the biggest one i asked i just
went and asked the research pile where
on earth is the biggest dead zone it's
in the arabian sea where all the rivers
from
um
india and pakistan dump into the arabian
sea
and it has 63
700 square miles of dead zone in the
arabian sea the second biggest dead zone
is in the gulf of mexico where
um
we have um
the
the rivers
you know going into the gulf we're
talking about the mississippi and the
missouri and all their tributaries and
things like that
and so that is six thousand seven
hundred i think or six thousand three
hundred
um
square miles of dead zone and then we
have all these troubles with
reefs i was doing a zoom last night
late with the people in the philippines
and they have problems with all of their
reefs having trouble
and so they have the same problem there
with the reefs and the reefs of course
have the same problems that they had
over 500 million years ago
when when we had these mass extinctions
i'll get to that in a second
and we're now going through these same
things that people went through
500 million years ago
going through the same problems
this is this cycle
okay and it's always due to
uh or i shouldn't say it that way i
should say it's always associated with
there you go it's always associated with
glacial events
now why would that be
well
um if we get down to the bottom line and
people always ask me okay just give us
the bottom line wallet what is it i say
well it's the damn dams it's the dams
that caused the problem wait a minute
there was there was no people 500
million years ago well there were but
you know they died
on the mass extinctions these as you
know pre-human human hominids um there
were 12 of them over the years
and so what do you mean okay well here's
what's happening
um when they had
these
extinctions again they were always
associated with glacial
events which would last
thousands of years
in some cases millions of years
and so what was happening
well
glaciers always push in front of them as
they're growing and moving they always
push in front of them more rains
m-o-r-a-i-n-e-s moraines and these
moraines are dams
which are made from the silt and the
sand and the gravel and the boulders the
glaciers are pulling off the walls of
the canyons and off of the
soil in front of them on the sides of
them they have lateral moraines and
crown rains and snout moraines and tail
marines and some glaciers have five or
six marines and some glaciers have one
but they always have at least one
moraine
now these dams can just totally shut off
the flow
of a stream or a river
are redirected in either case
where the water was going for thousands
or millions of years suddenly now gets
redirected in other directions instead
of going easy goes west instead of going
northeast it goes
west completely you know 45 degree angle
or maybe just shut it off totally and
create a lake
like in
like what happened um in uh lake tahoe
like what happened in glacier national
park
these sort of things in yosemite
national park and so forth um
all these lakes when you look at the
lake tahoe it's 1 400 feet
deep okay
because it was formed by a glacier in a
canyon
and so on
and that's another story what's going on
now at lake tahoe if we have time we'll
talk about that
and so what happened here well
when these glaciers redirected
the water or shut it off completely
and you know allowed thousands of feet
of water to build up behind these
glaciers was in the moraines which acted
like dams
and in modern times when you go you look
at australia
they have no glaciers in australia they
have i think 3 000 plus glaciers in new
zealand but they don't have any glaciers
in australia and of course the biggest
reef on earth is the great barrier reef
is 1 400 miles long is made up of about
3 000 small reefs and islands
and the center of the great barrier reef
is in trouble but the northern one
and the southern 25 percent are in good
shape
and that's because
um
of man-made dams and reservoirs 183 of
them on the east coast of queensland
which the great barrier reef hugs and so
the center of the great barrier reef the
food supply has been shut off by these
dams which are man-made
but it doesn't matter if the dam is a
moraine made from glaciers or a man-made
dam and still shuts off or redirects the
flow of these minerals
and so that's why we had all these
problems so how did it how did it bottom
line manifest itself
well
you've all heard of global warming i
mean everything is blamed on global
warming oh i was expecting a boy baby
but it was a girl that must have been
global warming everything is caused by
global warming
and so
global warming is a fact there's no
doubt about it but it has nothing to do
with fossil fuels i'm going to say that
again global warming is a fact but it
has nothing to do with fossil fuels i'll
give you a hint
you've all
forgotten about your car in the parking
lot in the summer time and you had the
windows rolled up you didn't leave it
open a half inch or an inch i mean if
somebody wanted to get in your car it
doesn't matter if your window's actually
closed all the way or
an inch you know before it's closed all
the way they're going to hit it with a
hammer or a tire iron or something like
that and break the window
so they can pull the
thing and open up the door and so don't
close those windows all the way when you
close the windows all the way the sun's
rays go through the glass and the
windows and the heat builds up in the
car but it can't go back out the other
direction
and so that's why kids die and dogs die
and stuff like that when they leave them
in the car with windows rolled up
because it gets to be 120 degrees in
there
okay
and
that's
not global warming but it's a little
event that you can repeat in a car and
you can repeat in a
valley or a mountain so how does that
happen in a mountain i mean well what
happens is if you're not
utilizing that carbon dioxide the carbon
dioxide builds up and so let's say the
carbon dioxide's building up the sun's
rays are going through the carbon
dioxide blanket if you will like the
wind in the car
and the heat builds up underneath that
blanket of carbon dioxide
and it gets hot and so that's why you
have global warming so why then do we
have this to the big question is why do
we have a blanket of
of um carbon dioxide it is not caused by
fossil fuels there is no fossil fuels
that were being burned in cars and
stoves and things like that over 500
million years ago so you can't blame the
global warming from 500 million years
ago to 2 billion years ago you can't
blame that
on fossil fuels because nobody's riding
cars back then
okay now coal did not exist until 400
million years ago when these dams
these moraines if you will
dammed up all the rivers just by dumb
luck all the rivers you know on earth
were blocked up by these moraines and
glaciers a huge
earth global
glacial event
and
these
glacier moraines dammed up all the
rivers and the creeks and tributaries
going into the swamps which were just
filled with algae
okay
making oxygen because algae of course
has
chlorophyll in it and chlorophyll is a
sort of a kingpin when it comes to
[Music]
things like photosynthesis you've all
heard of photosynthesis now they teach
photosynthesis in school
but they teach it all wrong
they say well photosynthesis
uses the sunlight
and chlorophyll
to break down carbon dioxide into
carbon chains and oxygen and your body
makes sugar out of the carbon chains
well that's only like one percent
correct
all right now what happens here is this
when you have
um
carbon dioxide being produced
if you have everything right the carbon
dioxide gets turned into oxygen in
carbon chains
and the carbon chains are used by plants
to make
um sugar yeah but also carbohydrates
also amino acids also proteins also
enzymes
also fiber
many many things are made from that
carbon
okay it's not just sugar
and so the oxygen of course is very
important to all of us aerobic critters
including human beings
and
they always leave out the most important
part of
photosynthesis so the title of my news
release is going to be dr wallach's laws
of photosynthetic disruption and global
warming photosynthetic disruption is why
we have global warming not fossil fuels
being burnt in cars and stoves and
things like that
all right so let's look at at um
photosynthetic disruption
so
if you don't have 20 there's 20
nutrients because the the act of
chlorophyll and the chloroplast which
are mitochondria these energy creating
little things inside of all our cells
that have chlorophyll in them they're
called chlor they rename them
chloroplasts when they have chlorophyll
in them
and
they're designed to again break down the
carbon dioxide gas into carbon chains
and oxygen carbon chains and oxygen
which is good but it takes 20 nutrients
for this it's a string of biochemical
reactions it's not switch on switch off
it takes time to go through these 20
different uh reactions i i wouldn't say
20 about 18 reactions or 20 different
nutrients
and
there are places on earth where these
nutrients don't occur and that's why we
have deserts and things like that
because and that's why he had animals
and people migrated through those areas
because they know if they tried to live
there for a week or two they'd all die
okay and this is why we have dead zones
okay when you look at again the arabian
sea and india
and pakistan
i didn't realize this
but india has ten thousand
glaciers
india has ten thousand glaciers all
around and below and on the sides of uh
the the
um himalayan mountains
and each of these glaciers have anywhere
from two to four or more of these
marines
and they blocked up all the the flow of
minerals down into the arabian sea and
that's why we have sixty three thousand
seven hundred square miles of dead zone
in raven sea
isn't that crazy now you throw in the
hundreds of dams that they've also made
man-made dams in india that aggravates
the problem because they're just adding
more
um stoppage of these minerals getting
into the arabian sea
to
be co-factors for
the um necessity for for photosynthesis
and that's what's happening in
um oregon
the columbia river in the columbia river
basin
has 250
dams and reservoirs
all right you're starting to get the
picture already this is not difficult by
the closest or the biggest one
okay and so they have uh 18
hydroelectric dams on the columbia river
they have total of 25 dams including all
the tributaries any other and all these
other reservoirs and things and they
shut off the flow of these minerals
into the ocean and that's why we're
having this new dead zone on the pacific
coast of oregon what are they saying
about that uh rebecca
what are they saying about the dead zone
in oregon
well i need you to tell me dr wallach
because i haven't plugged into the news
lately okay well what they're saying is
we don't know why but there's a dead
zone forming off the coast of oregon and
of course
they they have no earthly idea well
that's because they've shut off
the flow of those nutrients necessary
for photosynthesis to take place just
because you have sun and chlorophyll
that's only like
10 of it
you need those other 20 nutrients to go
through that chain of biochemical
reactions to make those conversions they
always leave that out
and so that's why we're in this problem
now we can siphon we can auger we can
pump all those nutrients from behind the
dams
and uh so forth and get them to go
downstream people don't have to give up
their electricity and things like that
we're not asking them to do that
there'd be no way to do that okay and so
uh basically what you have to do is find
a way to get the nutrients down into the
ocean into these bays and and send seas
and so forth and we can eliminate all
these dead zones in six months
now what's happening with the
um
things we call reefs well wreaths are a
community
um location
there's two requirements to build a reef
one is a polyp it's kind of like
a shrimp
kind of related to a shrimp or or
jellyfish and stuff like that
they're a non-vertebrate but they do
require oxygen
okay these polyps
coral polyps they call them because they
make coral reefs and coral reefs are
made out of
calcium carbonate
limestone
and
the
coral polyps take the
calcium out of the ocean water and
construct these reefs
but these polyps require an enormous
amount of oxygen
okay so how do they guarantee
over these billions of years that
they're going to get all this oxygen
well guess what
chlorophyll
algae
and so they live as a community the
algae in the coral reef and the coral
polyps and the algae takes the carbon
dioxide out of the air and out of the
water and produces
oxygen for the polyps to make the reefs
they are a community of these two
different organisms and they grow
together
now
the
you know there's always a bell-shaped
curve
and so
i knew there had to be another piece to
this and it happened here with lake
tahoe about a month ago now
when i was a kid i was a boy scout i was
an eagle scout i was an explorer scout
and every year for about 15 years
our troop 495 in st louis county would
help the firefighters put out forest
fires and brush fires and grass fires
and prairie fires and things like that
in the midwest so we're very very proud
of that we got lots of merit badges and
kudus and things for helping the
community and so forth our scout troop
but i know what a forest fire looks like
forest fires they usually have 95 of the
fire is in the floor of the forest
burning all the leaves and the brush in
the bottom and every once while a tree
will burn or it'll fall over in the wind
and stuff like that and burn on the
ground
but when you look at these
reports two months ago when this fire
started they evacuated 22 000 people
from south lake tahoe
okay
okay i think they called the kaldor fire
but anyway
um when you when you look at what was
going on there they show these fires
going in south lake tahoe and the crown
of the trees are burning and there's big
balls of fire that are 100 feet in
diameter 50 feet above the tree
i say what is going on there that's not
a typical forest fire i mean i thought
of first of all are they hitting methane
from from these old
uh oil wells that were digging up there
you know north of sacramento and all
this kind of stuff what's going on here
okay well what's going on is this
this is the bell-shaped curve
all right well for the past
10 years algae has been growing
in lake tahoe
it's been growing and growing and
growing you can almost there's so much
algae in lake tahoe you can almost walk
on the water like jesus walk on top of
all this
all this algae
okay
and so these algaes are
converting all this carbon dioxide that
was around there and that that's what
was stimulating the algae there's so
much food for the algae the algae is
going crazy and filling up the lake
but
the algae is converting all this carbon
dioxide to oxygen
and so the reason why these fires were
driving crazy and having crown fires in
the trees and far above the trees is the
air was burning because all this algae
was creating oxygen
and that's why the fires look different
because it was driven by oxygen that's
why they had seven thousand firefighters
and they still haven't been able to put
that fire out until just a couple of
days ago the fires moved i don't know
100 miles away from lake tahoe
and now they're getting it under control
because it's moved away from the source
of oxygen
and so that's why they're able to get
under control now because it's a
different environment than it was when
the fire was in south lake tahoe
and so all this is going to be in this
news release and much more great detail
i have all these different nutrients
listed in some great detail and so forth
and
what they do and so on
this is an unimpeachable series of
events
uh and i i figured it's going to have to
be a big news release like this because
if they just start talking about it
and it talks and things you know half a
dozen people will get it the other half
dozen people
won't hear me and there'll be half a
dozen people who believe that a global
warming is caused by fossil fuels and
they will want to kill me okay to keep
me shut up and so i figured there better
be this big news release out there so
that
literally billions of people will hear
the news all at the same time
and i have experience when i discovered
the first non-human case of cystic
fibrosis and these monkeys at the
yarkees primate center was working for
nasa in georgia
you know i got the medical schools to
confirm that it was cystic fibrosis
and but i didn't tell them it was in a
monkey
and then when they sent me their letters
to confirmation 1977 we didn't have
emails at least i didn't back then and
so they said you know this is classic
examples of civic relations and i told
them it was a monkey i said at the very
least we got you know an animal model
now for a city i was in every newspaper
in the world for three months
and then i got permission to do biopsies
and the other baby monkeys in the colony
which the whole diet had been changed
all these behaviors took away the monkey
biscuits and monkey pellets and they
gave them carrots and cucumbers and
things like that and all the baby
monkeys there had cystic fibrosis
because of nutritional deficiencies and
so i was supposed to give a lecture
to the
national science foundation
um and i had it up and i gave him a copy
of it and they fired me from your keys
primary center
because they said well if you're saying
it's not genetic i'm saying that's right
it's not genetic it's actually a simple
nutritional deficiency say you're out of
your mind this is a glass this is a
classic example of a nutritional excuse
me of a genetic issue okay well and so
they fired me that's when i went back to
school and became a naturopathic doctor
and then i'm a marine
uh navy seal and myself uh we were we're
i'm gonna use the cure here we were
curing kids with muscular dystrophy uh
with a dietary thing because i took a
similar disease called white muscle
disease in animals we call it
musculosphere in humans they said mr was
genetic and jerry lewis and the telethon
were raising they raised two billion
dollars in 20 years to
actually
uh
finance the research to find a cure for
monstrosity well i gave jerry lewis uh i
don't know half a dozen of these charts
and we had this navy seal marvin
take it to him and sit there and talk
and walk him through it he understood
what we were saying he took him to the
net to the uh bus christopher
association before he turned around and
walked out the door they fired jerry
lewis and shut down the telethon after
20 years and two and raising two billion
dollars they fired jerry lewis i
purposely gave it to jerry lewis because
he figured he's so well loved and known
around the world they might fire me but
they're not gonna fire jerry lewis they
fired jerry lewis because he said
mustard if he wasn't genetic
all right well here we go
um and so also
the mothers were not laying on their
babies causing babies to die of sudden
death syndrome
babies were dying of hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease and april
16 2013 i got a federal judge to force
the national institutes of health is
that correct oh the fda excuse me the
fda they forced the fda to put these
nutrients into baby formulas which i've
been trying for 25 years to get done and
doctors are saying all these minerals
are poison
and they put them in there and megalon's
very sharp in a year and a half
um sediment death syndrome disappeared
muscular dystrophy disappeared and
and the um
um let's see here oh uh city cabrosis
disappeared those three diseases
disappeared because all three of them
were simple nutritional deficiencies not
genetic and not mothers sleeping on the
babies so the medical system got it all
wrong by a billion miles
okay did they ever send me a bottle of
wine did they ever invite me to come
speak to
their medical schools
did they invite me to speak to a
national organization of ob gyns or
pediatricians no
they just said well we hope he dies
before us and then we can discover it
and twist in our direction
that's why you haven't heard anything
about that they're waiting for me to die
well they're gonna have to wait a long
time
okay and
that's we're gonna do this news release
this time we're not going to depend on
one person or one group this is going to
everyone at the same time because it's
too big of stuff the global warming is
easily dealt with but we have to deal
with it from the standpoint of science
and that is these 20 nutrients have to
get to
the plants
that have the um
the series of
biochemical reactions that are necessary
to convert carbon dioxide into carbon
chains and oxygen
chlorophyll is not enough and of course
400 million years ago
all these glaciers killed all the swamps
and all the lakes and any place that had
algae in it and that's why coal farmed
there was no coal before 400 million
years ago 400 million years ago coal was
farmed because glaciers pretty much
destroyed all the the algae on earth
and
um
it became peat moss to fill in where
algae had been and 83 percent of coal is
algae the other 17 is peat moss
and it formed 400 million years ago
before that there was no coal
but since all the algae died
over a sixty thousand a hundred thousand
year period
it all became coal 400 million years ago
so with that story i get so very excited
we want everybody to get on their 90th
century nutrients take the healthy brain
and heart pack i've been doing that for
74 years i've been gluten-free so i can
maximize absorption for 74 years i'm 82
years old most people think i'm in my
50s when they looked at me or listened
to me i'd watch my energy level and so
on
and we have worked out these programs
for over 600 different diseases
i've run into people
um rebecca
who are on
15 20
25 different prescription drugs they're
seeing 14 different doctors
and the doctors say well you know they
don't have to pay for their own pocket
insurance pays well they're milking the
insurance system just like a dairy
farmer milks a cow
okay and of course they get kids in
college and they tuition is doing so the
doctors don't mind building these
insurance companies you get the tuition
money
i take these same people and in three to
six months they're off 20 different
prescriptions and back to a normal life
because all these prescriptions are just
treating the symptoms doctors were
taught to manage disease not to prevent
or cure them the reason why we're in
trouble my last sort of little diddy
here before i turn it back over to you
rebecca is
this thing we have here with the kovid
i remember very clearly i was watching
fauci on tv he was saying when this when
when they first diagnosed his code
um
in 2019 he said
don't worry about this this covet thing
isn't nothing virus flu is much more
dangerous than the covid 19. uh just
wash your hands distance yourself six
feet wear a mask and in a month or two
we'll have the vaccine out there and
just all go away be history it's in
nothing virus
well let me tell you what there's
nothing virus has done to the usa
as of this morning's numbers these are
this morning's numbers we have 41
million 558
infections
we have 674
547 dead
i mean this is like water zone
casualty levels you look at india
with five times our population we have
332 million people india has 1.4 billion
people they have 33 million
infections we have 41 million
they have 441 000 dead we have 674 000
dead so since they have five times our
population why do they have fewer
they only have two thirds are dead
and we and we have um about eight
thousand not eight million more
infections than they do so what's going
on here
well india has two populations the
northern
nine states were occupied
for a hundred years by the british
taught them to eat gluten wheat brown
rhinos taught them how to grow it in the
southern 20 states and seven territories
they live like asian they live on rice
and sweet potatoes
and squash and beans and
things like that well because of that
difference in their diet because of that
hundred years of occupation by the
british in the northern united states
95 of all the deaths
from covenant in india
occurs in the northern united states
only five percent occur in the southern
20 states and seven territories
eighty-seven percent of the infections
occur in their northern nine states and
only thirteen percent occur
in the southern
uh 20 states and seven territories
because the difference in diet they're
saying people are homogeneous people are
not different people and when you look
at
i'll give one more example here and then
over you
and that is
uh let's look at a good one here let's
look at um
oh let's look at florida versus
australia
let's look at florida versus australia
and um
australia has 25 million people and
florida has 23 almost 24 million people
florida has 3.4 million infections and
australia has 58 000.
florida has 46 000 dead
and australia has 1 000 dead so what's
the difference
australia as forty percent of the
population
are
they're indigenous people in florida
fifty percent are indigenous peoples
blacks and
um latinos
well it's diet
the latinos the blacks the indigenous
people in florida live on wheat broth
around oats
and in australia everybody there eats
maize corn
rice sweet potatoes beans and squash and
seaweed and that's the difference it's a
dietary thing
because when you have the right diet
your immune system works
when you don't have the right diet your
immune system doesn't work and you can't
get the nutrients to your immune system
to it can do this job
so i'm very excited about this news
release because each and every one of us
can control the environment i want you
to use our bloomin minerals in your
house plants put two teaspoons of our
bloom and mineral crystals your
houseplants every month water just
watering your house plants
is an insane thing there's no nutrition
in water it's water but there's no
nutrition you need
you know there's 75 minerals in our
bloom and minerals and so you need to
put two teaspoons in every house plant
and you know when you water it
every month
and outside in your gardens and outside
when you're bushes around the house and
stuff like that put some of those
blooming minerals around there
and
the global warming will go away because
once you give plants with chlorophyll
the 20 nutrients they need
to break down carbon dioxide into oxygen
and
all these different compounds
like fiber and sugar and carbohydrates
and amino acids and fatty acids and
stuff like that
then there's no more excess carbon
dioxide duh
so over you i'm so excited i can't wait
to be like a week to 10 days this news
release is coming out great detail i
mean we're talking detail
well i can definitely feel your
excitement about this dr wellick and so
one thing that i really appreciate
and maybe not everybody knows is not
only
are you a naturopathic doctor who
started out as a vet
with
uh
as a and as a pathologist but you have a
degree in out
agriculture i can't even speak today
that goes beyond animals
that's right well yeah the whole
agricultural thing always two pieces
number one
i wanted to find out
how to
deal with um getting nutrition because
again uh
um
let's see here
1958 excuse me 1958 when i graduated
high school and i went to university of
missouri in ag school my my purpose to
going there was to be a scientific
farmer so we could eliminate all these
diseases that i was seeing in animals i
was seeing in myself i had
20 different doctors try to cure me of
problems i had they didn't have a name
for the diseases i had back then today
it's autism and add and adhd and stuff
like that and they were going to
institutionalize i mean i didn't sound
good to me
um and from they diagnosed me when i was
four years old by the time i was nine
they were going to institutionalize me
because i was getting aggressive and
hurting other people and stuff like that
and so these 20 doctors got together and
said this guy's got to be put in an
institution my mom said i asked her what
does that mean she said well they're
going to put you in a hospital i said
well how long is it going to be said
well maybe for the rest of your life
because they can't figure out what you
got
that didn't sound too good for a
nine-year-old and so i sat down that
night while they were sort of starting
to pack my clothes and everything and
then we live on this farm so they're
packing now so in a week they're going
to take me to this institution
and so why is it that i'm the only one
in the family that has this problem and
the animals that we're going to kill and
eat in three months they don't have the
problem we're all eating the same food
they said wait a minute we're not eating
the same food we're giving those animals
little alfalfa pellets with vitamins and
minerals in it so the next morning
i threw my cheerios and my wheaties and
oatmeal out to the chickens
and um i got the alfalfa pellets from
the barn put milk on it and in three
days time of eating those alfalfa
pellets with milk for my breakfast
cereal
guess what i cured myself in three days
and i knew when i was nine years old
that doctors didn't know anything about
nutrition i knew when i was nine years
old the doctors didn't know anything
about nutrition and so that's why i
wanted to go back to school in
agriculture in 1958 and and come back
and be a a scientific farmer and raise
food that had all this nutrition in it
to save people from all the miseries
that our family went through because of
me
and
so that's how it all started
and that's why you see these books i
have so many things in there
one of my
first books that really dealt with it
was of course um
uh let's play doctor but the big one
is rare earth forbidden cures we have a
cd that goes along with it rare earth
vine cures
the first five chapters all it
talks about is kids diseases that are
caused but yeah there you go they're
behavioral diseases physical diseases
biochemical diseases in kids
they're caused by just simple
nutritional deficiencies not genetics
not autoimmune which doctors say because
that way insurance will pay for it and
they get to milk the insurance policy
like a dairy farmer
milks his dairy herd
so thank you yeah we have a cd that goes
along with that
and um it's one of those things
you can add 25 to 50 healthy years of
your life
and you're going to save an enormous
amount of money because you're saving
enormous amount of unnecessary misery
because when you take these supplements
you more than pay for it in other words
you save so much money by just avoiding
the bad foods bad foods tend to be
expensive
the problems they cause as well is just
they're expensive when you buy
so if you stop buying the bad foods just
eat the good foods and supplement you're
still saving a lot of money
and you'll add 25 to 50 healthier as
your life minimum and why not be like
some of these
famous biblical characters like
methuselah who lived to be 969
or moses who lived to be 300 and so on
why not
okay it's
one of those
of course biblically
um it was god said and let man's years
be 120.
and if your family right now our average
lifespan in the united states is 75 it
used to be 79 but because of this covet
thing it dropped down to 75 we're
leaving 80 years on the table because
human
life expectancy is 155 we have the
capacity for everybody to live 155.
and that right now our average lifespan
is 75 cdc just came out with that like
three months ago
we're leaving 80 years on the table
rebecca
why would you not want to spend those 80
years with the people you love why would
you not want to spend those 80 years
doing the things you love to do
why are you so willing to give up 80
years when it's just going to have you
change your diet a little bit and add
some supplements to it
and it's that simple
but you've got to be proactive you can't
wait for the world to do it for you you
got to do it
that's so very true dr wallach and it is
so simple
and but i think one of the biggest
things is
people just don't know
and that's why we have this program to
help provide
information
and share
knowledge
so that they can also
have this this
reality that they're in control
yeah well here's a question rebecca
what if you you have this car you loved
and you kept you know you've been going
to this mechanic for years and you had
to take that car in every month for some
kind of terrible disasters going through
and everything
what would you do
well
i would do more of
maintenance and preventative stuff yeah
i would change mechanics
well yeah
yeah because he's not fixing the problem
he's just putting band-aids on it yeah
exactly coming back
yeah i say don't put oil in your car
you're just wasting money by putting oil
in your car put dirt from texas and
there's bound to be some oil in it
that's dirt from texas an insane person
wouldn't do that
but when a doctor says just eat well
don't waste your money on vitamins metal
just eat well i get everything you need
doctor every doctor says that to their
patients when their patients ask about
violence meals
and i asked people to say what'd your
doctor say about this he said well he
said i can get everything i need just by
eating well don't don't waste my own
meals and but they don't say it like
that they don't say it in the shy way
they my doctor says they're beating
their chest like tarzan my doctor says i
can get everything i need just by eating
well why waste my money on vitamins and
minerals
i said well i do have a a company i have
another company i sell coffins i'm going
to give him my card for my coffin
company just remember me when you die
[Laughter]
well and and i
you know i'm one that heard that
supplements don't do anything for you
except for make expensive urine
yeah and so how and so what was what has
been your experience what benefits have
you gotten by supplementing properly and
eating correctly
so it's the supplementing properly dr
wallick that's the big thing
because i used to cherry pick i used to
hear oh this doctor says i should take
this for this and that's for this and
that's for this
and i wasn't getting any results
but when i started supplementing with
the full 90 essential nutrients
i
well within three months
i had no more radiating pain down my
arms legs into my hands
into my brain
um i had no law no longer had any body
aches
whatsoever
i had lost 20 pounds
my migraines those are the first things
to go bye-bye
and
oh i am
that was something well this is the oh
rebecca how long had you had how long
had you had migraines
since i was eight years old dr wallach
so you're talking about 30 years
oh thank you
oh i had them i
i had had um
um 40
42 years
there you go and
and so in about four to six months it
went away
two months might be an exception two
weeks
okay you're not an exception
if everybody will get rid of the bad
foods take the 90 and whatever secret
sauces are necessary for whatever
specific disease they have
two to six weeks it always goes away
yeah
it's been incredible
absolutely incredible and
just five years you know i've lost
a hundred pounds without
strenuous exercise
yeah i love your exercise without
supplementation is suicide
and i would be able to do it without a
ton of exercise i mean i go for walks i
love to hike you know i love to swim
but it's not a daily strenuous type
intentional i'm exercising for an hour
twice a day
yeah there you go
giving my body those minerals
isn't that amazing
it is
that is well thank you for sharing your
personal story and of course uh you were
on george nori this last tuesday
and you didn't even know that if your
your testimony was on there and your
your voice you were telling the story it
was a beautiful i said that's rebecca
and it was it was a beautiful thing and
i i think george is really stunned by
your story okay because he knows you're
on his team
and um that sort of thing and so i think
he didn't realize
your personal story until he i'm sure he
listened to that testimony many times i
i would bet you he plays it once an hour
um
jonty and i had a lot of fun recording
that
okay well good
it it took a lot of time to get that
short segment
yeah well you you did you did it
perfectly so thank you john t and thank
you rebecca it was a beautiful thing
yes thank you dr wallach
um and i just want to thank everybody
who is on here with us today
and getting information to empower
yourselves and to share with others
about how you too
can just
gain
and claim
a better life a better health journey
and for those of you who are on with us
please if you have questions raise your
hand you will find that option in the
zoom menu to raise your hand because we
are going to be going through questions
here and try to get them quickly thank
you everybody who's put questions into
the chat
um and again if somebody invited you to
this program
make sure you get back with them to get
information on how to order the products
if you have never ever ordered anything
from youngevity before
you can go to our website askdoclive.com
and we have a store there and also on
our website we have all the replays i
mentioned that before but we also have
dr wallach's most popular publications
so i'm super excited that we have all of
that in one place
and we're able to to help people get the
information they need
if you're unclear of what you need we do
have the contact us there on the website
as well you can send us an email one of
our certified holistic health coaches
will return that email with the
information you need to help find the
products right for you
we also do have a
call team that is standing by at eight
five five
nine four nine
seven
now this is for people who have not been
sent to this program by anybody and
who have not ordered products v4 ever so
we do have that call team there for you
now dr welling let's go to the first
hand
okay
that first hand is martin
martin go ahead and unmute yourself i
just sent you a request
and thank you so much for having your
camera on we
do want to ask that if you have a
question
please make sure you have your camera on
because that tells so much i
think we have a good picture here i hope
i don't know i'm trying to yes
okay let's let's get going we can hear
it okay
um my significant other has a problem
she has this diarrhea right after she
eats
and she has some stomach pain on the
left side
from the um i'm assuming from the
digestive tract
um do you have any ideas
okay well how old is she
um she's 56
okay how much does she weigh
um 180
okay how tall is she
uh five foot two
okay
now does she have any other issues does
she have any skin problems any eczema
dermatitis or psoriasis
no no skin problems does she have any
respiratory problems asthma bronchitis
copz hiccups
no
okay
um does she have any dizziness or
ringing in her ears
um no
okay does she have anything going on her
hands or wrists or arms
um
no
okay does she have any low back stuff
um yeah she has some low back pain
okay some sciatica
okay
and then uh does she have anything going
on with her heart any irregular heart
rate any afib
fast heart rates low heart rate
no
okay good all right
well
you know at uh let's see here at 56 now
she's got sort of the middle age stuff
going on here
and so basically she i believe she has
a gluten problem which will cause
stomach problems and intestinal problems
and diarrhea
um
so she needs to get rid of all the
gluten you have to get rid of gluten
yourself the dog the cat the bird fish
everybody living in the house has got to
be gluten free no wheat no barley rye no
oats none of that kind of stuff
there are no such things as gluten-free
oats gluten and oats is called gliadin
anybody who says they're selling
gluten-free oats should be put in jail
for murder okay
okay i'm dead serious okay
then at a hundred and hundred and uh
you say 180 pounds five foot two
okay so five foot two she's about 65
70 pounds overweight here so i wanted to
get three boxes of our
i'm hearing talking in the background or
something okay i think she's trying to
update her weight is 165 now so
okay
it doesn't matter i still want her to
um
she still needs to get off all the bad
foods no fried food no processed meat no
oils no glutens no we buy ryan notes no
sugar no carbonated drinks even the diet
one's got to go and then i wanted to
have
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month two healthy brain and heart
pattern with a full dose everything
twice a day i want her to get our msm
get two bottles of our msm so you can
take three of those
um with each meal that's gonna support
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligament tendons connective tissue disc
between the vertebrae bone makes bone
itself and then i do want her to get
those three boxes of the keto caramel
bars they come 10 in a box and she's
going to need one a day per month
and
uh doesn't have to be the same meal
every day but just a complete meal would
be one of those bars
and water
okay plus her supplements
okay that'd be one meal a day
and then um
after say two months she could go to two
meals a day of a keto bar one me two
meals a day two days out of the week but
the other five days of the week stay on
one meal a day okay don't go to two
meals a day for all seven days just only
two days then
and she'll lose a half a pound of two
pounds a day then i also want her to
have some vitamin d3 i want her to take
three of those twice a day
as two vowels a month i want her to take
the um
let's see here our ultimate enzyme she
could take two of those before each meal
say five to ten minutes for each meal
with a couple ounces of water she also
needs our
glucogel if she prefers the liquid she
could at her body weight she could take
two quarts a month take a an ounce of
breakfast out to dinner
of
our
uh liquid glucogel
if she prefers a capsule she could take
five of those twice a day it'll be two
bottles a month
and let's see here
uh she doesn't have any blood pressure
issues
or diabetes
no blood sugar problems pre-diabetic
yeah okay well pre-diabetic okay then i
wanted to get two bottles a month for
sweeties so you can take three of those
twice a day
and
sweeties take
okay
keep going
then i want her to for drinking other
than water of course i want her to use
our rebounder sports drink it has 100
nutrients in it 75 minerals and 25
vitamins and amino acids so she could
take
she could have say at her body weight
she could drink
two of those three of those
from the time she wakes up in the
morning
uh i wouldn't drink it after three or
four o'clock in the afternoon because
she might stay up all night but if she
has plans to do something
you know work all night or drive all
night some places she would want to take
one say at five o'clock or something
like that
but um this will all go away i think her
diarrhea and her stomach thing
can be it can be due to two things
number one primarily to a gluten problem
secondly it could be due to
what's called gastroparesis
which is due to the skull having
osteoporosis squeezing the 10th cranial
nerve
but almost always there's always a heart
issue or a
respiratory issue that goes along with
it also if it's the skull squeezing the
10th cranial nerve all right so give us
a call every couple of weeks because
she's going to see dramatic improvement
um
and it's toll-free so it doesn't cost
you anything to call
and um it's one of those things you get
wholesale prices on the products and if
you get on auto ship i will pay the
shipping doesn't get any better than
that
okay so rebecca back to you
all right thank you dr wahl all right
and let's just let's see we're at the
top of the hour we've got three minutes
you want to take a quick break or take
another question let's take a quick
question
all right let's go to tiffany
tiffany go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
hello tiffany
and tiffany if you can turn your camera
on that would be fantastic
hello
oh there it worked sorry about that it's
an honor and privilege to speak with you
well you're very kind yes i was i caught
you on coast to coast
and tuesday nights
yeah
several times anywho um
i'm tiffany i'm 56. are you from england
are you from england no i'm from
portland oregon so it's fascinating
hearing you speak about that today
okay
i um recently had had an afib in july
with a cardio
conversion
and i've got um sleep apnea i was
diagnosed with
and i've got a diver
i'm 300 pounds and i'm five just about
five minutes okay wait a minute diver
you talking about diverticulitis oh yes
yes sorry diver particulitis yeah okay
how much do you weigh in how old are you
uh 300 pounds and i'm 56 years old
okay do you have any diabetes or high
blood pressure
no probably pre they told me to watch my
numbers on the diabetes mm-hmm
okay
all right
and you how tall are you
five nine and a half
i'm sorry say five what
five nine oh five nine okay at five nine
i'd like to see you weigh 160 170 so
you're 130 pounds overweight so i want
you to get um again three boxes of our
keto bars
uh there's ten in a box i want you to
take one meal a day a keto meal for two
months and then after the two months you
can go to two meals a day for two days
out of the week the other five days a
week stay at one meal a day
the other
two meals i want you to eat like an
asian you cannot have any of the bad
stuff no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens a weep alright no
sugar no carbonated drinks
no okay
and i want you to ideally if finances
are not an issue for you
ideally um you would take um
three of our healthy brain and heart
packs for a month to full dose
everything at breakfast lunch and dinner
you also want to take the ultimate
excuse me the msm get two bottles a
month of our msm swing take three with
breakfast free with lunch through dinner
that's going to support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage lemons
tendons connective tissue disc favorite
bone makers which is important here
because afib
is your
skull you have osteoporosis it's called
squeezing the 10th cranial nerve
vagus nerve causing this thing it's not
a heart issue it's actually osteoporosis
squeezing that nerve you ever get any
hiccups
no not really
okay do you have any copd or asthma
asthma
no
no asthma
yes asthma yes asthma okay now did you
have asthma as a kid or is it just
recent or no a very recent
yeah okay and so yeah this is you're
going to be amazed the asthma will go
away very quickly the pre-diabetes will
go away very quickly and you'll start
losing half a pound of two pounds
a day
and the okay and the a-fib will go away
because again
um i
i want you to get two bottles a month of
those uh msm so you can take three with
each meal that's gonna support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between vertebrae bone range
including the skull you'll rebuild the
skull do you have any ring in your ears
or
any dizziness or balance problems
um a ringing in the ears um
comes and goes
yeah okay experience periods of really
long period of time that that occurs
and then other times it doesn't yeah
yeah it's called tinnitus is the name
part to the doctors see it's not unusual
there's 12 pairs of cranial nerves
there's 12 pairs of cranial nerves and
you can have three or four or five or
eight or ten of them being squeezed by
the skulls so you get all these
different things and doctors will refer
you to their golf buddies or their
tennis partners who are neurologists and
hearing doctors and
your eye and nose and throat doctors
right
insurance pays for it so it's not
hurting the patient because insurance
paying for it but it pays for their kids
college right
exactly
okay so the tinnitus will go away very
quickly because it's being caused by the
same thing
uh as the afib
isn't that crazy amazing
yeah okay amazing yeah so yeah you're
you're gonna
i do want you to call to say every
couple of weeks and give us you know an
update it's toll-free i want to know
your weight i want to know how your
tinnitus is going i want to know how
your a-fib is going i want to know how
your pre-diabetes is going all that kind
of stuff we'll walk you through this you
are you are going to be a blessing for
so many people tiffany thank you
you are a blessing to all of us well
thank you you know i can't wait you live
in oregon right
yeah well i'm in california currently
but yeah i'm i have a place in oregon
i'm just enjoying the california
sunshine currently okay i always wanted
to have breakfast at tiffany's yes
they named the movie after you yes
okay thank you so much okay
god bless you okay rebecca
all right well dr wellick let's go ahead
and
take a break and okay everybody who's on
with us please don't go away we will be
right back here on ask doc live get up
stretch
make sure you're staying hydrated
and again if somebody invited you to
this program make sure you get back with
them not only to get the
their link
to get products but to thank them for
sharing this information with you we
will be right back
all right thank you everybody for
hanging here with us while we take that
quick break we appreciate you allowing
us to do that well you're not allowing
us we're just going to do it anyways
because we need to stretch also make
sure we're staying hydrated
and
oh it's just so exciting i can't believe
we are already in september of this year
and there is so much going on
that
you know we can be proactive we can be
reactive
we can
there's so much we can do
so much we can do to help ourselves stay
as healthy as very possible
um
and they're simple it's so simple
removing foods from our diets
adding proper supplementation
makes a world of difference
um somebody had put up here
in the chat and i love it i love how we
have testimonials that are going up in
the chat where people are sharing their
experience also
because i know i'm not the only one
that's getting great results from dr
wallach's products it's just incredible
how
something so simple can make such an
impact in our life and in the life of
others
so we can live closer to that 120 year
mark and not be in pain
and that's the biggest part for me
because with all my pain i totally
was not looking forward to getting an
older and now that i'm 50 and i'm
feeling younger than i did when i was in
my 20s
i'm
saying bring it on i'm ready
so as soon as dr wallet gets back we
will be addressing more questions and
getting information to you from the man
himself
so
dr wallach is back absolutely fantastic
thank you can you hear me can you hear
me okay we can hear you
okay wonderfully
so dr welling let's go to a question
that came into the chat here
okay um there was actually two questions
that had to do with honey
and wanting to know if one wants a sweet
can honey be used
and
the next one is does cutting
sugar out include honey
okay well if you have diabetes you need
to exclude honey
until your diabetes is gone right
because why would you want to keep
throwing fuel on the fire and trying to
put the fire out and you keep throwing
fuel on the fire
and so you have to you know
um which i say
what you want to do is eat
a
low
of
low sugar fruit like bananas
as opposed to eating apples kind of
thing
eat berries
instead of
instead of pears
eat berries
berries be very very good and
it's one of those things where
you know if you want to get rid of your
problem you'd be really strict for
say three months
and then
you can introduce one drop of honey
for breakfast in the morning see how
that works for you you know test your
blood sugar again
but you know you can't just be
i wouldn't say say mindless
because you you're wasting your time
throwing your money away on supplements
because you're you're throwing fuel on
the fire on the back end trying to put
the fire on out on the front end
so we got to get all of the parts
working the way that they're supposed to
and then
that's right and then you can then you
can do start with one drop of honey see
how that works for you
yeah i would do that so
yeah even those of us who don't have
those issues anymore
i mean let's think about this
you you correct an issue why would you
go back to doing a lot of stuff that you
were doing before that got you to where
you're at
mm-hmm
can be bad
[Laughter]
natural is not always good yeah natural
can be bad and of course you always
remember
um
the medical system misses it by a
million miles so many times
mothers were not laying on their babies
to create sediment death syndrome so
gabriel says much history were not
genetic
um
uh down syndrome is not genetic it's
actually a simple nutritional deficiency
early in pregnancy i've reversed them in
pregnancy
um
before the three month mark you know say
it two months i reduced down syndrome
some very famous people i have beautiful
pictures of their kids uh born perfectly
normal freaked the doctors out because
they wanted them to have an abortion and
everything and they said they the moms
would take this kid to the doctor and
say you wanted me to abort this kid are
you out of your mind and the only thing
that per the patient did wrong was they
kept going to the same doctor
i would change doctors if they were
insisting on an abortion
and the kid was born normal listening to
me
why would you keep going to that doctor
that said abort the kid
it doesn't make sense to me they you
know
the the doctor has to pay the price for
being so wrong
yeah
yeah it doesn't make sense to me either
it makes me cringe dr wallach
oh goodness
okay so
um
martha is writing in dr wallach and she
had an x-ray of her lungs
she's
37 years old
pounds
um at five foot eight
and the x-ray showed that there was
subtle
intersysteal changes in the mid and
lower right lung
so they're telling her she has
intercystial lung disease
um which has another term of
pulmonary fibrosis or scarring or
inflammation i mean all of these
different things
and her symptoms include shortness of
breath coughing
and she is looking for your
recommendations
to address this she did find that the
back there's a bacteria called
check this mycoplasma
that is a common cause of this condition
also
yeah it's called rheumatoid arthritis
yeah that's the same bug that causes
rheumatoid arthritis there is a there is
an antibiotic called menocycline like
the little bait fish minnow okay minnow
cycling uh that will kill the mycoplasma
so she needs to get you know a six to
eight week course of mental cycling and
shame on the doctor if he didn't
prescribe it for her
and um
then she she's at 145 pounds she's given
all the bad stuff no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat produce no sugar
no carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go 145 pounds she's right on that
cusp but because she has something
that's potentially serious here uh
especially with this covered thing going
around you don't want any serious lung
stuff going on so i'd have to take two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
and full dose everything twice a day i'd
ever take two bottles a month or msm so
i can take three with each meal i want
her to take our oxy body
take an ounce of our oxy body
okay
twice a day i'll ounce it you know say a
half hour before breakfast and half hour
before dinner not during the meal but i
wanted to take it half hour before
so she can absorb it and get the oxygen
maximum
and then
i want to support her immune system
uh so i want her to have the cell shield
rtq she can take three of those twice a
day as the quercetin and this is the
queue very important here and then i
also want her to have our killer biotic
which is a um i don't know eight or nine
ten different mushrooms that are support
the immune system and anti-inflammatory
she could take three of those twice a
day i do that i don't have any problems
i take the killer biotic just to prevent
stuff
um
and
i think that's where we need to go but
it's imperative to stay away from the
bad stuff i mean
she cannot even cook gluten for somebody
else
i get so many people say i say you got a
gluten plum why don't eat gluten well do
you cook in the household you have a
home you know i'm the mom i'm the wife
i'd do the cooking i said okay
do you what do you cook for your husband
well he wants oatmeal for breakfast
every morning he wants spaghetti and
effort well that's why you have a
problem you're cross-contaminating in
the food preparation service so you
cannot have gluten in the house
if he wants to eat gluten more than he
wants to be with you divorce him
otherwise you're going gonna die 25
years early
right
right well and so we need to add some
something here she added um i also have
pain in my knees shoulders and sometimes
my wrist
okay well the msm is going to go there
yeah okay two bottles of msm's you can
take three with each meal that's gonna
support and promote mains repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
makes your bone itself wouldn't hurt for
her also to take some glucogel she could
take um uh if she prefers the liquid she
could take a
um
oh i'd go with one quart
of the gluco gel take a half ounce of
breakfast half pounds of dinner time if
she wants to go
with the capsule she could take five
twice a day which is what i do i weigh
142 i take five of the capsules twice a
day when i'm on the road i'm at home
i'll take the the liquid and then also
we have a product called uh flexi care
plus
it it's biochemically we put this
together
okay so we we make this
flexi care plus
and if you look at the stuff on the back
on the label
it looks like
bone broth you're probably too young to
remember bone broth when people would
put chicken bones and beef bones and
lamb bones and fish bones and stuff like
that in some vinegar water on the stove
every night and leave the wood still go
it would simmer and we'd fight in the
morning who's going to get the bone
broth because we knew it would make our
joints feel better and all that kind of
stuff
and so uh she could take uh that bottle
has enough uh for two doses a day for a
month and so she needs to take an ounce
twice a day
um uh for a month
uh and but this will be forever i i've
been doing this forever
[Laughter]
and i i take i started out with taking
the five three times a day okay
now i'm maintaining with five twice a
day
well there you go
and and i feel great i'm running up and
down stairs
isn't that amazing
to go from the fear of falling whether
i'm going up or down at 19 to now
running up and down at 50.
i think it's fabulous dr wallach
well we're very proud of you rebecca and
thank you
yeah well thank you for sharing of
course i again i cannot say enough i
think george
the other tuesday this last tuesday just
a couple of days ago
he was
he was so enamored i could just tell by
his voice he was so enamored by your
testimony
um
that was a beautiful thing
uh he's a gym
yes
he's awesome
all right next let's go to our next hand
that is up dr walek okay and we have
frank
frank go ahead and unmute yourself
okay
all right hello everyone
yeah um
um
57 180 pounds
by foot five
um been having problems with gout for
the past 15 years
so now uh doctor recommended alpurinol
got 300 milligrams a day for the past
five months
and when i with that i also get some
gout flare-ups so she recommended that i
take some prednisone when i have
flare-ups
okay so so i'm dealing with that right
now i'm still always in pain you know i
still always you know still get
flare-ups
and okay
okay so you have any other issues do you
have any diabetes or have a pressure
um blood pressure is like borderline
like 130 over 85
okay you know so it's getting on the
higher side
okay but i do have um
uh i had an abscess perianal abscess
with the fistula
and the doctor now suspects that i have
crohn's disease
so okay do you know do you know what
crohn's disease is
it's an influence inflammatory disease
of the uh small intestine
yeah what do you think causes that
i'm thinking gluten i was listening to
you get young guys you get an a plus
i was listening to the other night on
coast to coast and uh
so
did your doctor tell you to give up
gluten
no
well i would immediately change doctors
yeah because he's enjoying you your
insurance policy
yeah so and and the thing is i've had a
couple surgeries already so i don't know
if they're
they're ready for another surgery you
know so okay now now are you talking
about your knees your hips your back
what are we talking about surgeries
oh for the uh fistula
oh the fistula okay it's just kind of
yeah okay now do you have um
let's see here are you coloring your
hair you have any gray hair in your
beard your hair head
um i have a little bit of gray yeah okay
okay
family pretty much yeah it's not genetic
it's due to nutrition it's due to a
nutritional deficiency
okay and do you have any varicose veins
or hemorrhoids in your fistulas
um
external hemorrhoids yes
okay
now these are some skin tags and stuff
down there that's why the doctor thinks
it's crohn's
yeah we'll see
skin tags white grain silver here
hemorrhoids fistulas
varicoses veins spider veins are all due
to
the same deficiencies caused by
nutritional deficiency which is
secondary to
gluten gout is caused by
uric acid
okay which you get from beans and shrimp
and
things like um crab and see seafood and
that kind of stuff okay so
here we go
you need to get rid of all the bad foods
and for you you got to get rid of the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens no wheat no
butter i know it's no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go uh you got to get rid of all
the things that contain uric acid we're
talking about beans and seafood
that kind of stuff
now you can have fish but you can't have
um shellfish
got it
like pop cod is okay you can have cod
you can have
you can have um trout you can have
salmon
you can have tuna you can have stuff
like that but you cannot have
uh you cannot have crab and
um that shrimp and that kind of stuff
okay because they have the uric acid in
there
then
okay then i want you to
uh
let's see here i think we got rid of all
the bad stuff
then i want you to
um
180 pounds i want you to take two of the
healthy brain and heart patch per month
two health advantage hard packs per
month or full dose everything twice a
day i want you to get two bottles a
month for msm so you can take three with
breakfast lunch and dinner and they will
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between a
vertebrae bone makes your bone itself
and
for your gout if you still have some
residual pain and things like that in
the joints
we do have our cm cream and our trauma
oil from our aromatherapy all division
you can put five drops of the tremolo
oil and a teaspoon of cm cream and put
it on your gaudy joints
okay whichever one's hurt and it'll give
you a couple hours of relief
and then
for the high blood pressure
i want you to
uh
preheat or early high blood pressure or
mild habit pressure i want you to take
uh two bowels a month of our ultimate
daily
classic tablets take three twice a day
and they will support healthy blood
pressure
and healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries in the brain the coronary
artery in the heart the kidneys and so
forth you don't have any urine issues or
kidney issues or bladder issues or
anything like that
no those seem to be okay
okay good
but just getting off of the gluten
and taking the the nutrients is going to
be a big big big big benefit for you
you'll notice within two to four weeks
you're gonna be a different guy
okay
yeah one thing i've noticed is grocery
shopping though it's difficult to
determine what is gluten free there are
gluten-free sections but then you know
whether it's like mustard or mayo or
stuff like that
you have to read the labels
okay gluten contains wheat butter and
oats
those four grains you cannot have
anything with wheat brother and oats in
them there are no such things as
gluten-free oats
okay
all right okay then give us a call every
couple of weeks frank because you're
going to have a great great testimony
i love when we get guys like yourself uh
and just by doing these things you'll
gradually lose some weight at five five
i'm five six
and i weigh 142.
uh five five you should be when a guy
you know 150 160. so you'll lose 20 30
pounds here
just by getting off all the bad foods
you'll slowly lose about a half a pound
you know a week or something like that
it'll be a slow but you you'll you'll
lose the weight okay yeah i think it
should help you
okay
let's hear from you because your
testimony is going to help a lot of
people
all right okay thanks you bet god bless
frank
all right thank you frank let's go to
william who has
his hand up william
i see that your camera is covered but it
is on there you are
go ahead and unmute yourself you who are
on live with dr wallach
hello doctor how are you you look like
you rebecca you should look like him and
but william you do need to speak up your
voice is very
quiet
okay okay so
well we can hear your voice but can't
see you but tell how can we help you
well uh every morning there you go there
we go
every morning when i wake up about an
hour later i start getting a little bit
dizzy and kind of a combination of
dizziness and fatigue on it's really
most days it dissipates and disappears
within a few hours
but it lasts long enough that's it's
actually severely life limiting
okay okay we'll stop there for a minute
now when you say dizzy is do you feel
kind of light-headed or do you feel like
the world's going around
it's um
lightheaded
okay do you have any ringing in your
ears any tinnitus or ringing or buzzing
or wishing in your ears
it's not associated with those exact
periods but that does happen but in a
really minor way
okay
uh then let's see here do you have any
um
um do you ever get sleepy after a meal
no not really
okay so when you eat a big dinner you go
sit on the couch watch tv you don't fall
asleep an hour later
no
okay uh do you have any skin pumps any
eczema dermatologist or psoriasis
no
okay any irregular heartbeat afib fast
heart rate so heart rate no
okay
uh let's see here do you have any low
back issues
no um sometimes i i feel like it's like
a minor
the most minor of sensations like i'm a
bit uncomfortable but it's nothing like
what i would call pain i don't
understand if that's actually
subclinical to you or
okay how much do you weigh and how old
are you
um 190 pounds 48 years old
okay and how tall are you
six one
okay all right so that yeah your weight
is good for your height that's good
um
so
your only your only real problem is this
sort of dizziness you have
okay uh which can be called tinnitus uh
ringing in the ears or dizziness fatigue
which can be called vertigo or
low blood sugar could be caused by that
and the fact that you know an hour so
after eat breakfast it seems to go away
but
those are your only problems
so and you have a little bit of
something going on in your low back
so here's what i would do stay away from
all the bad stuff no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no gluten so we
probably noticed no sugar no carbonated
drinks and even the diet one's got to go
i want you to take 190 pounds two of our
healthy brain and heart packs that's our
big hammer in the tool box two healthy
brain and heart packs a month to fold
those everything at breakfast and dinner
once you get two bottles a month of our
msm so you can take three with each meal
and the msm is designed to support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
your bone cell
and
let's see here
this will um
help you rebuild your skull rebuild the
disc between your vertebrae and in fact
i'm gonna ask you a question were you
six two at one time did you shrink any
since you know you were 20 years old
you know it's possible um
[Music]
i think i may have been six two at one
time it would have been a little while
back okay
all right that's that's useful
information
all right um let's see here they do have
some gray here
right
yeah and do you have any varicose veins
or spider veins or legs or feet
no um i should point out the there is a
patch of gray up here when i was 13
years old i was hit on the head suffered
a mild mtbi
that's the only gray hair that i believe
that i have
okay nothing in your beard or mustache
no
okay well do double do a double look for
us all right
and so
again i would go there and i would also
even though
you've never been diagnosed with
pre-diabetes or diabetes this fatigue
thing would always wake up in the
morning with that kind of stuff uh could
be low blood sugar so i would go ahead
and get two bottles a month of our
sweeties you could take three twice a
day
and let's see if that doesn't help with
that but we're talking about we've
already dealt with the low back issues
we've dealt with the tinnitus and
dizziness stuff
and maybe a pre-diabetes thing so let's
let's go there and then call us every
couple of weeks
if you visit the doctor for a regular
visit or for any reason
let us know what the doctor says and so
on we'll walk you through this because
again at your age
years you know you have these sort of
vague things going on there's sort of
the early red morning lights that
there's something going on there so it's
good that you're looking to do something
about it because it can be
catastrophic say a year or two down the
line but you're seeing the red warning
light now
when you see the red warning light in
your dashboard or your car you don't
wait until the car blows up before you
take it to the mechanic right
okay
okay okay well let's talk to you in a
couple of weeks here william thank you
super thanks
back to you rebecca
all right thank you so much william next
let's go
to
jolin
jolin go ahead and unmute yourself
hey jordan
hi i love you guys
rebecca's testimony today interested me
because i did the migraine thing since i
was eight years old two
i'm 73
i've gone through chemotherapy now i
have neuropathy in the toes i'm going
through a second round of cancer
treatment it's not chemo but it's a very
expensive injection
now i'm i've listened to you enough to
know that you you guys are great in what
you do
and i'm gluten free for about four years
and sugar-free
i even uh can't have a a house guest
here because she wants to cook white
bread i said it won't work here you know
i mean she wanted she wanted to move in
rent the room i said no it won't
so i am i'm serious about it
i've started your your 90 and so forth i
am a little bit financially stressed
because of all the therapy i'm going
with with chemo i mean for your hair for
cancer okay okay we'll stop there for a
moment all right okay were you diagnosed
with cancer by biopsy or wow
uh
cat scans
and blood tests
okay what type of cancer do they say you
have uterine
it's called saris it's for older women
it's very aggressive and i 30 of the
people live with it
okay when were you diagnosed
2018 march of 2018 i had surgery
immediately
okay so are things under control right
now
i had a cat scan just last about three
months ago it has
no it has not stopped it it's in the
lymph
nodes
okay
how much you weigh how much you weigh
okay and how tall are you five two
all right so yeah so their approach
hasn't quite gotten it right
no no he said he said chemo didn't work
for me so he put me on this very
expensive injection thing
how long ago it was your first treatment
for that uh
two weeks ago okay okay well here's and
this is for our general listening
audience you may be doing a lot of this
already but this is for our general
listening audience
so we want you to jo joel in
to give up all the bad foods no fried
foods and you're good to not let this
lady move in who's going to cook white
bread in your house that's good
no cross-contamination okay
no
again
absolutely um
no um
uh gluten no wheat protein rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks even that
one's got to go all that stuff
and then uh at 135 pounds i want you to
get one
a bottle a month of our um
uh or not model excuse me one box or um
health healthy brand hard pack another
brand of hard pack okay and i want you
to get another bottle of water slam not
from walgreens but arsenal because it's
got the five cofactors in there there's
one of our bottles of selenium in the
healthy branded hardpack so i want you
to take six a day you could take two
with each meal or three twice a day
whatever easier for you
and then i also want you to take our msm
get one bottle a month or msm take six a
day take three twice a day or two three
times a day again which is what's never
easier for you
and that's going to support your
immune system by supporting
the bone marrow cavity which is your
immune system okay your white blood
cells your antibodies and that kind of
stuff
and i also want you to take our killer
biotic which is a i don't know maybe
eight or nine different mushrooms that
support the immune system
anti-inflammatory i want you to take
three of those twice a day i do that i
weigh 142 and i take three twice a day
or a kilobiotic just to support my
immune system i don't have any problems
i don't think i'm taking many wages as
prevention and then i also
would like you to take our btt 2.0
tablets take three of those twice a day
or two three times a day total six a day
that'll be two bottles a month of our
btt 2.0 tablets
okay now the the tablets do not replace
the btt 2.0 powder which comes in the
healthy band heart pack the powder is
vitamins and minerals the tablets
support your immune system and are also
anti-inflammatory and so okay
can i stop you there the treatment i'm
getting is called immunotherapy and it
is designed to boost my immune system i
go every three weeks i get injection so
it takes 30 minutes and i take a pill a
day
but that is designed to uh um improve
the immune system to okay eradicate on
one one you know can one point that's a
good thing but they're supporting but
they're supporting the immune system in
a different way than giving your immune
system the nutrition it needs to respond
to your treatment
if you're not getting this nutrition
you're not going to get the maximum
response from that treatment that's true
i understand i understand
okay good so they're two different
approaches here but they're both
going the same direction and yeah um the
nutrition will support that that
medication but if you don't do the
nutrition the medication is not going to
give you optimal results i understand
okay
another thing i have about about
rebecca's testimony about the migraines
i suffered that and i've i journaled it
and i found out
when i lived in the desert palm springs
for 30 years i never had a migraine
headache never when i moved back to
riverside corona
they started up again it's barometric
pressure headaches
it's by the way
it's the weather that's constant
and the only thing i can take is a very
exp
very strong migraine headache um
med you know prescription i don't want
to take any more and i found that
i belong to church where we don't do
coffee we don't do tea we don't do you
know anything like that
i found going back to two cups of coffee
a day
restricts the blood
the blood vessels and it removes the
headaches
i know i've journaled i went i've got i
love nutrition i've saved it all my life
the same
but i'm now experiencing it myself
what do you think of coffee
well we have
we have a coffee called java fit
and so you get you might try our coffee
uh you know we own the we own the
plantations and we fertilize our
plantations in nicaragua with our plant
minerals our blooming minerals
most of the most of the um
uh what do you call these cruise lines
with all these you know
yeah holiday ships and everything they
use our coffee
i worked aboard one of those
i was a hairdresser board a cruise liner
okay joellen we we gotta move on here
lady but thank you so much i love you
please don't forget every couple of
weeks and share your story with other
people will you please
that's what i'm trying to do
okay god bless
yes all right dr wallach let's go to
the next hand that that it is up and
that is anne
and go ahead and unmute yourself and if
you can turn your camera off that or on
rather that would be fantastic
you are on live with dr wallach
hello anne
there we go hold on and
so i sent you a request to unmute
let's pray that again
there we go go ahead dear
good morning good afternoon here we go
how can we help you okay so um i've been
on the be your 90 and 90 and uh blue
coach l msn healthy heart brain pack i
feel good
basically i have some questions i have a
bunch of questions and um i have an icd
defibrillator pacemaker i mean they had
to put one in because they needed
somebody to go to college i'm sure
um
okay you know you can't stop there
did you have afib
i had a ventricular tachyardia oh
tachycardia okay yeah okay yeah now do
you have any do you have any ringing in
your ears do you have any tinnitus or
ringing in your ears no
okay good all right so how can we help
you today
so um i would like to ask you if you got
you believe we need to get the covet
shots in the booster
okay well here's the deal um i have been
restricted from talking about
um the coveted vaccines and stuff like
that
okay okay i can't talk about that
the powers that be said you can't talk
about that okay so
everybody's scared to talk about that
and so um
i would just tell you this i personally
have had
the two of the moderna vaccinations you
know the month apart
um this is back in the early spring of
this year so
when
uh november december comes along i'm
gonna get the booster that's all i can
tell you that's my personal thing
and um but you know i've been taking all
the nutrients to support my immune
system and this and the other
vaccinations do not
kill viruses bacteria fungus trees they
do alert your immune system to the bad
dna and rna of the bad bugs
so that when the bad bugs come along
your body knows what to do
and that's all i can tell you
okay
thank you so i'm on all your supplements
and i feel good now i bought this
organic pea protein or gain organic p
protein and on your site you talk about
um longevity site it says about nuts and
beans legumes um this has not to eat
because they have phytates in them
phytates yeah why taste and that sticks
to the minerals and not to take the um
supplements within two hours or
something would you explain that to me
also this organic pea protein has one of
the ingredients that says it's all
organic organic coconut oil
and you said not to me
warning light warning light
no because that that's the sharp part of
the conversation it's got oil added to
it no bye bye
okay i got that
um
what um so
so i can't take the supplements if i eat
like beans or something or even can i
take people why would you do something
stupid like that you're going to give up
the 90th century nutrients so you can
eat beans
are you out of your mind
no i don't mean that but well that's
what you said well that's not what i
meant so but if i but you said to eat
beans and nuts like walnuts and
pistachios
yeah that's fine
you can make some beans
but not to take i can't take the
supplements sip on the supplements while
i'm doing this
okay you take the supplements in the
morning and the evening
have your you know
have
by beans you know we're talking about
beans and peas and stuff like that you
put them in some water and you boil them
and you eat them with a little maybe
some
salt and pepper on them right that's it
don't add oil
okay you don't fry them no fried beans
okay and so you got to be very very
careful what you're doing
you already have some bad issues or the
tachycardia
right
and so you don't be throwing oil in your
system
you want to be doing that okay
no fried foods no processed meats you
cannot have anybody living in your house
who does those sorts of things you
cannot cook those foods for other people
because you get caught
cross-contaminated in the food
preparation surfaces
and um
you know this is this is
life-threatening stuff
and so um if you're prepared to give up
25 years of your life
because somebody
demands having
you know oatmeal for breakfast or
fried beans then say i'm sorry you'll
have to go eat those things outside i
want you to wash wash your own clothes
uh in a laundromat
um come in the back door
and i'll i'll sleep in the den and
you'll sleep in the bedroom i live by
myself right now well that makes it easy
right
so um
but i sip on the tangy tangerine
throughout the day with water
okay that's a good thing
so that's okay and to eat that stuff too
yeah
okay but you don't have to eat good
stuff you can't eat any bad stuff no i
don't eat bad stuff i've been eating
good stuff for years okay well then then
you've been taking the tango tangerine
with the good stuff is no problem
okay can i take um can i mix the uh
beyond tangy tangerine with almond milk
you already you know the answer to that
yes
the answer is no
because almond milk has almond oil in it
no
so just good water huh
yeah and we have a wonderful water well
it's called icelandic water that's what
i make all my youngevity i put all my
young duty powders in our icelandic
water i make my tea with icelandic water
i make our java fit coffee with
icelandic water
um why would i want to use tap water who
knows what those guys are doing
down there you know
who knows what's going on in the water
treatment plant
right no i don't i use bottled water
all right thank you so much and
let's try to get one more in before the
end of the hour dr wallach okay
um let's go to karen
karen go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach i know i
wonder if comments and i'm glad we got
to you oh thank you so much
how do
oh you can hear me then yes god bless
you dr wallach i've been a listener
forever before you wrong
i take your stuff i called a long time
ago ucsd couldn't diagnose me for
seven years
and a script i finally went to scripps i
have i listed what i have but they
diagnosed me this wonderful modern
doctor who doesn't even give antibiotics
a lot he would love them but he found
that i went to him i it took me a year
to get him and i got lucky at scripps
but he i switched i went through kaiser
i've been through sharp i mean i've paid
330 000 out of pocket in addition to
paying blue cross revolution with my own
ppo doc just to get diagnosed i eat
organic for like 40 years i drink only
bottled spring water that's clean no bpa
i don't microwave anything plastic i'm
like a health nut my friends make fun of
me don't take i take zero meds i'm 67
i am five foot seven i weigh about 150
and i i was doing yoga pilates five days
a week and walking five days a week uh
speed walking with my neighbor i got
where i couldn't even walk i i'm in
business i had to close my business and
i run uh academies i also could not
teach i teach state board and i run
private post-secondary okay so what are
your what are your what's your
fatigue that's i'll tell you what i
listed it i have
diagnosed me with um
chronic active ebv they have a new name
for it as you know the seid i have a
chronic non it doesn't go to remission
this is by blood they send out the blood
scripts it's with a chronic infection
activation
they diagnose with a possible and very
high levels of microplasma infection i
heard you talking to a woman about that
you said there's you take that viral
series i documented it it's microplasm
and ammonia
yeah well yeah so mycoplasma you want to
take there's an antibody called minnow
cycling like the little baby would you
spell it out please doc
minnow m-i-n-o like the fish okay
because i documented that okay another
cycling and okay because it kills room
it kills mineral cycling pneumonia it
kills mental cycling arthritis which is
called rheumatoid arthritis right right
i don't have microplastics okay
mycoplasma gives you a positive ra
factor
and so
you need a six to eight week course of
the mental cycling in addition to all
the nutrients okay i take i've taken
your minerals the guy i bought
everything you had i took the one you're
taking the killer i took it religiously
for like six months i still take some
stuff i take all the stuff you that the
fellow on the phone gave me like the
reading on the pneumoniae thing like
from 0 to 99 normal range i'm 858 and
it's got a high flag
and i have on the um on the s on the
epstein bar chronic fatigue i had
written on the chat thing documented for
you i'm like the doctor was shocked
because he looked at all my records like
they did before i got there from ucsc
said karen i i remember this and said
i'm not happy with anything will you
retest everything i said doc i'm easy
tell me what i thought he said there's
no antibiotics for anything which i was
shocked when you said that one
but my antigens for my nuclear epstein
bi uh profile
i have only zero to 17.9 u slash ml i am
600 it has a red flag h
three and then another one is supposed
to be zero to 17 on 506.
and then on a zero to nine it's okay
well okay okay i'm going to stop you
there because we only have a few moments
we only have a few moments tell me tell
me what to take or buy or from you tell
me what to do
okay so i want to be clear on what your
complaints are because i'm wandering all
over the place and so i need well it's
chronic fatigue i'm only going by what
the doctor's side knows after all these
okay chronic fatigue okay and so plasma
yeah now did he say anything about
pre-diabetes or diabetes or hybrid
pressure no my blood sugar is normal my
blood pressure is normal everything's
normal you know what i mean yeah it just
you have chronic fatigue
yes severe it doesn't go into yes and he
was shocked and i mean he put me he
didn't say take he told me that he gave
me massive like detox and um he told me
don't eat anything with preservatives i
had gone gluten-free for almost nine
months to a year but it didn't stop this
i don't know why
well gluten-free okay stop gluten-free
is good
it's absolutely essential but right
gluten-free doesn't guarantee all 90
essential nutrients you still have to
supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients i did i did buy
okay so here here's but you can't just
do it for three months this is for life
okay now okay we only have a moment so i
want you to listen i'm documenting go
ahead okay okay you have just yeah you
have to stop talking and let me talk
okay i want you to give up all the bad
foods and this is for our listening
audience because there's lots of people
out there with your problems so
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat broth or iron
oats no sugar no carbohydrate drinks
even the dot one's got to go then i want
you to have two of our healthy brain and
heart packs that's our big hammer out of
the toolbox right now with a pandemic i
want you to have two of our health
abandoned heart packs a full dose
everything twice a day i want you to get
our uh two bottles of our msm so you can
take three with each meal they're big
bottles you can do that take three at
breakfast street lunch or dinner time
and they will support and promote
mainstream pair of cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
a vertebrae bone makes your bone cell
and i want you to also
to
uh get our um ultimate daily classic
tablets go ahead and get uh two bottles
of those a month and take three twice a
day and they will support and promote
healthy blood flow through
uh blocked arteries whether it's in the
brain the coronary arteries in your
kidneys or anywhere in your lungs or it
might be
um
how often three twice a day
three twice a day okay got it just two
hours a month
okay
and then
um
this uh let's see here you also need to
support your immune system i want you to
get our killer biotic i want you to take
three of those twice a day um they're
these um high profile mushrooms that
actually support your immune system once
you take three of these capsules twice a
day i do that myself just for prevention
is there a killer body take three twice
a day it'll be two bowels a month
and then i also uh want you to you're
gonna have to get that minnow cycling to
deal with the microplasma and 160 you
want a 68 weeks course of that and i'll
be happy to talk with your doctor if he
wants to do a three-way with you he and
i i'll be happy to do that thank you
and then um
let's see here for something to drink
for energy we do have a rebound or a
sports drink with a hundred nutrients
and it's got 75 minerals and 25 bottoms
amino acids
and then let's see here
how much is also
how many bottles or how many of that
would you recommend
i would go at 150 pounds you could have
say two or three servings a day but i
wouldn't have them after four or five uh
in the afternoon or after three or four
in the afternoon because it might keep
you up all night
okay so okay
and then um
i would also
uh be sure that you're going to
um
see here something anti-inflammatory i
want you to take uh something
anti-inflammatory for your lungs and
your heart and your brain and so forth
and so i so i would throw in
uh let's see here i i i would throw in
our let's see here what's a good one for
you i i would go
let's see here um
rebecca what would you what would you
say you've gone through a lot of this
yourself what would be your
recommendation for anti-inflammation for
the brain i like de-stress capsules do
you take de-stress i was just going to
say de-stress hands-down dr wallach okay
so you agree with that so i would go
with a de-stress get get two bottles a
month karen or d-stress capsule take
three twice a day and they're for the
brain metabolism
and
and people tend to leave those out
um well my doctor says i can just eat
well i'll get everything i need no
when you have problems you need to
really really really make sure that
you're getting everything you need by
putting them in your mouth you have to
know what you're putting in your mouth
you can't just hope it's in the food
because plants do not need these things
and it's just sort of that's why we have
global warming that's why we have these
problems um because everybody's just
believing that everything just works and
we just you know wait long enough
everything will work right no
you got to fix the problems so let's
hear from here let's hear from every
couple of weeks i will definitely get
back to you i thank you please thank god
bless you and thank you oh thank you
dear okay thank you for your time and
thank you rebecca
thank you karen have a great one
all right
so dr wellick
i've got a couple questions
one of them
has to do with
ultimate daily classic
okay
ultimate daily classic is amazing
but unfortunately
we cannot ship it to canada or the uk
what product would you recommend as a
substitute
okay as i said there's two things you
can do there's a substitute we use the
ultimate daily tablets the big yellow
ones
okay we have a lot of people in canada
who use our ultimate daily tablets
and it has those nutrients in there not
as much
in terms of micrograms and milligrams as
it is the elder daily plastic but it
does have those nutrients in there also
in our healthy brain and heart pack
those nutrients are in there
okay
but
here here's the real answer to the
question
we also have people who live near the
border in canada to the us border and we
have our we have
uh distributors there who are up lines
of those people and so what they do is
they just you know they go have a lunch
together uh once a month and they just
hand transfer it to them
the canadians will come across and have
lunch with them
and they hand it to them
and they put it in their
briefcase or their backpack or whatever
they cross back over the border into
canada but if they live in northern
canada and way way way away from the
border then just go with the ultimate
daily tablets the big yellow ones
now
i have some canadian
customers who have po boxes on this side
of the border and when
the borders are open they come and check
their
mail and have a nice lunch
so that that is an option when the
borders
are open
there you go
now i have a question dr wallach from
sandra
um
let me get okay
okay so while i'm looking for that
let's
go to another question and this
gentleman is 63 years old
5 foot 7
200 pounds
has type 2 diabetes
had a
quadruple bypassed seven years ago
now his kidneys are failing
functioning at 13
he has a port that was put in his arm
for dialysis but hasn't been used yet
when putting that port in the doctor cut
the nerve
um and he's been having pain and
numbness in his hands
he started getting pain through his
lower wait a minute
he wait a minute wait a minute he cut
the nerve and he's got pain in his hands
the kidneys are far far far far away
from
um right but they were putting a fistula
in his arm did i miss this oh
oh yeah you didn't say that of course
fistula innocence
okay
so here's the deal
um
when you have
kidney issues it's really the arteries
that are blocked
99 of the time the kidneys are fine it's
just the arteries are blocked that's why
people get problems
quote with kidneys unquote
and they their blood pressure goes up
they
they can go to a pharmacy without
prescription get the you know urine test
strips and pee on them and it'll tell
them what's going on
um with their urine and so forth
and so it's not unusual for people to
get diabetes and hybrid pressure and
kidney issues because they're caused by
the same thing
all right so here we go 200 pounds 63
years old
this guy needs to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens or wheat bread rhinos
no sugar uh he needs to take two health
advantage heart patch per month to full
dose everything twice a day he needs to
get the msm two miles a month so we can
take three with each meal that'll
support promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue which includes walls of arteries
and veins very important here
he also needs
uh two bowels a month or a sweetie so we
can take three of those twice a day
don't cold turkey off his diabetes
medication uh as his blood sugar begins
to drop he can slowly reduce his
medication based on the numbers as he's
been taught to do and then the same
thing with the kidneys um
the the ultimate daily classic tablets
will support healthy blood pressure and
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries he needs to take i'd have to
take three of those three times today
will be three bottles a month of the
ultimate daily classic tablets and that
will support again healthy blood
pressure healthy blood flow
through the kidneys
and we take people that haven't urinated
in 10 years they're on dialysis six days
a week and in just two weeks time on the
same program
they'll start urinating again so they'll
drop the dialysis down from six
a week down to three a week then after
two to four more weeks they're totally
off the dialysis they've been on
dialysis for 25 years because they
didn't want to um get a kidney
transplant and so just after six or
eight weeks
on the supplement program and changing
the diet all the bad stuff goes away
we do this literally thousands of times
a year this is very very common that we
do these things
because they're very very common
diseases and of course
that's why doctors love people to get on
dialysis because they get to milk their
insurance policy and send their kid
through college
all right thank you so much dr wallach
now sandra's question is in regards to a
72 year old female
five foot three
220 pounds
she also is diabetic and has been for 30
years
um
her doctor told her that she had should
have an a1c of 6.5 it is at 9 or ten
sometimes nine glucoses range from 72 to
150 and she is on insulin
and other oral medications she has high
blood pressure
okay
um and arthritis
i was going to say she got to have some
joint problems at 72.
yep
so what would you recommend for this
okay okay she well rebecca she's got to
get rid of all
the bad stuff right no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens a
wheat broth around those no sugar no
carbohydrate drinks even that one's got
to go
i want her to take
um let's see here two healthy brained
heart packs per month two healthy brain
and heart pattern a month to full dose
everything twice a day i wanted to get
two bowels a month or msm so you can
take three with each meal that'll
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between a vertebrae
bone makes your bones health and then
for the high blood pressure she needs
two bowels a month of our
ultimate daily classic tablet so shake
three twice a day again don't cold
turkey off the blood pressure medication
but as her blood pressure drops she can
slowly reduce her medication based on
the numbers usually it just takes two to
six weeks to get off the medication and
then the diabetes she needs to take
two bowels a month of the sweetie so you
should take three of those twice a day
again uh do not take um
and get off all the blood excuse me all
the
diabetes medication
whether they're injection or oral but
slowly reducing medication based on the
numbers
and
as the
numbers begin to drop she can slowly
reduce the medication and usually again
within two to six weeks she's an
ex-diabetic i don't care she's been a
diabetic for 40 years
okay
and then let's see here does she have
anything else i've missed
i think that's it
okay using the joint issues
yeah okay one other thing for the joint
issue you know uh we talked about the
msm but i do want her to have some
glucogel
uh she could take um
here's what i wanted to do i wanted to
take the cal toddy
gel in the caltonia there's vitamin d3
in the kel toddy
and 220 pounds you get two quarts a
month taking ounce of breakfast on
dinner time so she can be taking one
product instead of three products and
she can get the d3 you get the glucogen
should get the extra calcium okay so
it'll be two quarts a month of the cal
totti take an ounce of breakfast ounce
at dinner time okay
awesome thank you so much dr wallach and
we are at the top of the hour the end of
today's program
of askdoclive.com
we thank you all for joining us again
get with the person that invited you to
this program
and say hey i want some of what they
were talking about
if you have not spoken to anybody and
you found this program on your own or
you're part of our subscriber base go
ahead and go to askdoclive.com
and you will find a full store there if
you have questions again use the contact
us and you'll be connected with a
certified holistic health coach that can
help you find out what products are best
for you
dr wallach thank you so much
okay well thank you rebecca thank you
john t yes for you guys
the two of you did the work of five or
six people today and so i applaud you
and thank you so very very much uh for
uh doing a great job and look forward to
uh next week
we are over time so thank you so much
for the section see you next week
bye-bye
goodbye everybody thank you jaunty bye
everybody